en france la vogue du vélo électrique
c'est une bicyclette classique renforcée
d'une batterie c'est moins fatiguant
beaucoup moins polluant qu'un scooter ou
une moto et aucun permis n'est requis
évidemment il ne faut pas être trop
pressé il junca stéphane linou sa moto
n'a pas bougé depuis un mois dorénavant
matthew billets se déplace en vélo
électrique
chaque jour il dépose ses enfants à la
crèche ensuite direction le bureau en
pédalant il déclenche l'assistance
électrique le moteur situé dans la roue
avant pire le vélo l'électricité est
stockée dans une batterie placée dans un
sac et la liberté du vélo c'est à dire
pas d'assurance vont le casque blanc
jean médecin mais pas encore dans les
couloirs de bus
je ne dépense pas d'essence pas
d'assurance le budget à part l'achat et
est réduit à rien
un système conçu et vendu dans un
atelier parisien olivier bireaud
installe ses moteurs sur des vélos
classiques il y à un mois encore il les
vendait sur internet
il a décidé d'ouvrir sa boutique succès
oblige
au bout d'un mois déjà le bouche à
oreille fonctionne bien il ya pas mal de
gens qui sont passés j'ai vendu pas mal
de quito autre option le vélo électrique
de série compter 700 à 2500 euros
les prix sont chers mais les ventes
décollent une progression de 50 % en
douze mois le leader européen prédit un
bel avenir au marché français la france
est peut-être le marché à part la
hollande bien sur le marché le plus
important en europe de l'avenir dans les
dix ans à venir
6000 vélos vendus l'an dernier ça reste
pour l'instant dix fois moins qu'aux
pays bas
mais le marché du vélo économes et
écolos devrait exploser au retour du
printemps
la santé